um so quickly people that are going to
go see this might need a little bit of a
refresher course from the first avatar
if I put 20 seconds on the clock can you
give me a rundown of what that first
film was about I mean no pressure right
Jesus okay you about ready okay ready go
uh man you know searching for meaning
travels across the Galaxy to find this
planet not only is he able to find
himself he's also able to find love and
he has to help this planet fight against
these Invaders that are trying to take
over the world
that that was good 18 seconds
that's actually the quickest City ones
ever well in 10 seconds there you go
there you go you know Sam recently
talked about and he talked to me about
it here tonight that James wrote kind of
like an avatar 1.5 for you guys to kind
of a refresh your course to see what Sam
and Terry had been up to in the past 10
years anything about that that you read
where you kind of like wow and what was
that like you know to see where they've
been and what they've been up to well
yeah I mean we last we saw them they
were getting rid of some of those Sky
people but they you know it was it was a
very big population they had all these
different colonies there on the planet
so 1.5 was about the continuation of
that war and the continuation of the
expansion of their love
and this the movie got recognition today
from the Golden Globes two nominations
one for Jim and one for Best Picture
drama your thoughts about
I'm very happy I'm
you know it's
put a lot of thought and work and love
into this and a lot of time and you
certainly know that it's time that he
spends away from his life and those that
are closest to him and his world
um for him to get that recognition it's
just the proof that everything that is
done with love can be recognized by many
finally uh Zoe can I take you back 20
years 20th anniversary of Crossroads
this year what do you remember about
your time on that set and shooting that
you were baby shooting that movie it was
just amazing it was I was surrounded by
amazing women from the director Tamara
to the producers Carly and and Shonda
the writer Sean their Rhymes come on
yeah and Brittany and Taryn myself I
just felt an Anson Mound it just felt
like it was such a beautiful experience
did you have to like kind of I mean
because you were really the actor you
and Taryn were the actors actors
Brittany was new to the the party did
you guys have to take her under your
wing Brittany was a natural from from
the beginning
[Music]